مدن عده في ايران احتجاجات نظمتها عائلات
الفتيات التي تعرضنا للتسمم في بعض
المدارس فيما سجلت حالات التسمم المزيد من
الاعداد لطالبات في خمس محافظات بينما لا
يزال الغموض يلف القضيه التي اثارت القلق
والغضب واشار موقع ايران انترناشونال الى
خروج مواطنين فاحتجاجات امام مباني وزاره
التربيه والتعليم بمختلف المدن بما في ذلك
طهران وصفهان وكرمانشاه واردبيل وادانوا
خلالها اتساع ظاهره تسمم الطالبات ورفعوا
شعارات ضد المرشد علي خامنئي وكبار
المسؤولين في البلاد ونشر الموقع عبر
تويتر مقطع فيديو وقال انه يظهر احتجاز
مسؤولي مدرسه بمدينه نسيم شهر التابعه
لمحافظه طهران الطالبات المصابات بالتسمم
داخل المدرسه لاسباب مجهوله واظهر مقطع
اخر تعرض مدرستين للبنات لهجوم كيمياوى في
مدينه همزان وكذلك في مدينه كرمان شا غربي
البلاد بحسب الموقع
[موسيقى]